so yesterday as many of you
listened to and watched and emailed me
about i interviewed donald trump's
former attorney michael cohen now
michael cohen disagrees with me or at
least you know i could be swayed but
i've been saying i don't believe donald
trump is ultimately going to be charged
with any crimes michael cohen believes
that he will
but michael's commentary was really
restricted
to the financial stuff that michael
cohen would know about meaning sometimes
overstating and sometimes understating
the value of different assets for the
purposes of either obtaining loans or
minimizing taxes or whatever the case
may be
there is now
another layer as to the possible
criminal charges that maybe would be
coming donald trump's way now i still am
very skeptical that this is going to
become a real thing but at this point
there's a member of congress that is
alluding to it you know so so i do think
that it's real enough that we should be
talking about it what am i talking about
here well yesterday we played
uh
we we rather we
reviewed text messages
that republican congresswoman
liz cheney
read
during a hearing
which came from various fox news hosts
and donald trump jr to donald trump's
former chief of staff mark meadows now
we're gonna now look at some video of
her talking about this and it's about a
three minute video i'm gonna play it all
so that you get the full context
pay special attention near the end where
cheney actually says
did donald trump through action or
inaction
corruptly seek to obstruct or impede
congress's proceedings i'll tell you in
a moment
why that is so relevant let's take a
look at the video
these text messages leave no doubt
the white house knew exactly what was
happening here at the capitol
members of congress the press and others
wrote to mark meadows as the attack was
underway
one text mr meadows received said quote
we are under siege here at the capitol
another
quote they have breached the
capital in a third
mark
protesters are literally storming the
capital
breaking windows on doors
rushing in
is trump going to say something
a fourth
there's an armed standoff at the house
chamber door
and another from someone inside the
capitol
we are all helpless
dozens of texts including from trump
administration officials
urged immediate action by the president
quote
potus has to come out firmly and tell
the protesters to dissipate
someone is going to get killed
in another mark he needs to stop this
now
a third in all caps
tell them to go
home
a fourth
and i quote
potus needs to calm this [ __ ] down
indeed
according to the records multiple fox
news hosts
knew the president needed to act
immediately
they texted mr meadows
and he has turned over those texts
quote
mark
the president needs to tell people in
the capitol to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
laura ingram wrote
please get him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished brian kilmeade texted
quote can he make a statement ask people
to leave the capitol
sean hannity urged
as the violence continued
one of the president's sons
texted mr meadows quote
he's got to condemn this [ __ ] asap
the capitol police tweet is not enough
donald trump jr texted
meadows responded
quote i'm pushing it hard i agree
still
president trump did not immediately act
donald trump jr texted
again
and again
urging action by the president
quote
we need an oval office address
he has to lead now
it has gone too far
and gotten out of hand end quote
but hours passed
without necessary action by the
president
these non-privileged texts are further
evidence
of president trump's supreme dereliction
of duty
during those 187 minutes
and mr meadows testimony will bear on
another key question before this
committee
did donald trump
through action or inaction
corruptly seek to obstruct or impede
congress's official proceedings to count
electoral votes
mark meadows testimony is necessary to
inform our legislative judgments okay so
that's a lot of different things that
she said
but at the end she says did donald trump
corruptly seek to obstruct or impede
congress's proceedings
this is being considered
the most direct signal thus far
that there is the
possibility
that donald trump might be charged with
pretty serious federal crimes what
cheney read there relates to 18 u.s code
subsection 1505 obstruction of
proceedings before departments
agencies and committees the issue here
of course
being donald trump's attempt to obstruct
investigation
into himself
and also
attempt to obstruct the proceedings
which would
correctly
assess joe biden the winner of the 2020
election and it reads whoever with
intent to avoid evade prevent or
obstruct compliance
with any civil investigative demand duly
improperly made
willfully withholds misrepresents
removes from any place conceals covers
up etc etc shall be fined under this
title imprisoned not more than five
years or if it involves international or
domestic terrorism up to eight years so
the idea here is that liz cheney is
hinting at possible criminal charges for
donald trump
over
the entire situation now that has
exploded for donald trump's former chief
of staff mark meadows involving text
messages involving a powerpoint which
very directly said here's how we would
do the coup and hear the different
elements that we would look at doing
there
a number of different legal analysts are
talking about this harvard law school
professor emeritus lawrence tribe
pointed out that refers specifically to
u.s code subsection 1505 18 us code
subsection 1505
and um cnn's ellie honig made a similar
comment when he was interviewed by john
berman and so this is now
going to be a question of whether or not
donald trump
could get away
with claiming presidential immunity that
would be the next layer here imagine
that this happens okay and again this is
why i see it as unlikely
but i'm a little bit closer to thinking
it's conceivable that there could be
charges although i the guy is not going
to spend the day in prison
if indeed they tried to charge trump for
his role
in any of these various obstructive acts
because there's actually no shortage of
them
he would
likely first claim that he had
presidential immunity for anything that
he did
now
the problem with that is how do you
justify trump's obstructive actions with
regard to investigations into him or
directions of others to obstruct how do
you justify that as a presidential duty
because at the end of the day
immunity
is limited based on the legal experts
i've spoken to in the scholarship that
i've read
the immunity is limited to his official
duties or things carried out clearly in
his role as president so
fortunately or unfortunately i know many
of you don't like this but when a
president makes a decision for a country
to go to war
and people die as a result of that could
be american troops could be foreign
troops could be civilians
it is very difficult to hold them
accountable
uh as if these were individual criminal
acts because they do have pretty broad
presidential immunity
could it be challenged maybe but the
point here is
we are now arguably outside of that the
argument that would be made against
trump's claim of presidential immunity
and there's a bunch of different people
who have tweeted about this and written
good commentaries how do you justify
that donald trump's obstructive acts
related to his own wrongdoing
would be covered by presidential
immunity and there are some people who
say yeah if the president does it it's
not a crime uh
hearkening back uh to richard nixon but
there is a debate about that and
fundamentally if there were charges
donald trump would likely try to assert
that he had presidential and has
presidential immunity on the basis of
what he did
and then it would become well are the
obstructive acts actually uh
uh covered by immunity and there is an
argument to be made that they are not it
would be a fight it would be a very very
big legal fight could be ages but the
first signal that maybe there are people
in congress a republican no less
thinking of crimes related to donald
trump's actions of course the crimes
would be up to the justice department to
bring it
still doesn't seem that merrick garland
seems super interested in that that'll
be a story for a different day
one of our sponsors is self-decode
self-decode is a genetic testing and
analysis platform that gives you tools
to gain insights about your health based
on your dna this is a new technology
we're still learning so much about
what of substantive value can we get
from these types of results but by using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning you can get personalized
insights based on your specific dna as
well as getting lab test analysis and
recommendations really a lot of
interesting ways to get information
about yourself through the self-decode
platform they never sell your
information they never give away your
information to anybody self-decode sent
me a dna kit to get my saliva i did the
test sent it back and in just a few
weeks i had my results i found for
example that genetically i'm not at big
risk for kidney stones
not at big risk for asthma
unfortunately i'm at slightly increased
risk of headaches which is true which is
true and the recommendations you get are
really simple and logical things
relating to sleep relaxation etc
very very interesting and this is a
technology that's going to develop and
mature significantly over the next five
to ten years self-decode is giving my
audience 25 off when you click the link
below and use the coupon code pacman